Hello, internet, and welcome to this
course all about open telemetry.
In this course, I'm going to
be showing you how you can get
full stack observability on the performance of
the behavior of your software project by using
open telemetry with your analysis tool of choice.
If you want to be able to tell why your project
or app is running too slow, is broken, or
you just want to improve its code quality.
This is the video for you.
But first, what exactly do we
mean by over telemetry? Well, let's start off with
the name itself, we have open so like open source,
and telemetry, which is an institute collection
of measurements or other data at remote points.
And that automatic transmission to
receiving equipment for monitoring.
The word telemetry actually comes from
the Greek root word Teller, or remote,
and metron, for measure.
And that's exactly what we are going to be doing,
we are going to be facilitating a
way to measure the performance of
everything we use in our app remotely.
With any app, when you want to start
looking at this kind of data, you have
two parts that need to come together.
The first is figuring out how to
generate and transmit that data.
And then the second part is deciding
what you are going to do with that data.
So in other words, how are you going to analyze
it? Open telemetry deals with that bus part.
Up until now there has been no real standardized
way of describing what your system is doing.
This is down to the fact that we
all like to think differently,
use different programming languages, different
machines, and a combination of different ways.
This was a problem, especially for those
wanting to build observability tools.
At the heart of open telemetry
project is exactly that,
a standardization for describing
what distributed systems are doing,
no matter what programming language
or computer systems you are using.
Today, the open telemetry project can
be described as a collection of tools,
API's, and SDKs, use it instrument,
generate, collect and export telemetry data,
so that we can analyze it later on with whatever
platform we wish by standardizing our data and
means we are not tied to anything in the long run.
And it makes moving from one analysis tool
to the next super easy, I will
not affect your historic data.
As I mentioned at the beginning,
this is an open source project.
It is made up of many, many
developers and their inputs.
If we have a look at GitHub here for the
project, you will see it is super transparent.
You can see the Governance Committee,
you can see the technical committee.
If you are interested in getting involved,
please do join their mailing list
and attend the community meetings.
You can even see all the meetings
that you are welcome to join.
Before we get started, though, I just want
to go into a little bit of what we're going
to learn on this course.
So let's break it down.
Okay, so in this course, first we're
going to look at what are microservices
followed by what is observability then we're
going to look at melt, followed by the history
of open telemetry, then we're going to
actually start by setting up a project.
We are then going to talk about tracing,
distributed tracing and context and propagation
before adding tracing into our project.
We will then move on to looking at metrics before
finally ending on our distributed projects.
I will end this course with where to go next.
We expect our websites, apps and online
services to load almost instantaneously
right? Think of the frustration some of us feel
when websites take more than two seconds to load.
on the backend a feat of engineering is needed
to keep a global system running to make sure
that you have access to Netflix or Instagram.
Only a tap away Let's have a look
at Netflix for a minute.
Netflix at its peak consumes 37%
of internet bandwidth in the US, there are
1000s of people clicking play at the same time,
with activity peaking in the evening.
Though, as a global platform,
it's a constant pick.
The challenge is how to run a service with
zero loss while processing over 400 billion events
daily, and 17 gigabyte per second during peak.
In today's video, we will dive deeper into what
types of systems power these amazing services and
how we can use data to get deeper visibility
into the insights of these complex systems.
Historically, developers about applications in
monoliths with large complex code bases, a single
monolith will contain all the code for all the
business activities and application performed.
This is all fine and dandy
if you have a small app.
But what happens if your application
turns out to be successful,
users will like it and begin to depend
on it traffic increases dramatically,
and always inevitably use requests
improvements and additional features.
So more developers are roped into
work on the growing application.
before too long, your application
becomes a big ball of mud.
a situation where no single developer
understands the entirety of the application.
Your once simple application
has now become larger complex.
multiple independent development
teams are simulataneously.
Working on the same codebase and simultaneously
changing the same sections of code,
then it becomes virtually impossible to know
who is working on what poetry does collide,
code quality suffers, it becomes harder and harder
for individual development teams to make changes
without having to calculate what the
impact will be to other teams and
teams can lose sight of how that code might be
incompatible with others, among other issues.
This generally results in slower, less
reliable applications, not to mention
longer and longer development schedules.
In come microservices, the main principle
behind a microservice architecture is that the
applications are simpler to build and maintain
when broken down into smaller pieces.
When using microservices, you isolate software
functionality into multiple independent modules
that are individually responsible for performing
precisely defined standalone tasks.
These modules communicate with
each other through simple API's.
microservice architectures let you
split applications into distinct independent
services, each managed by different teams.
It leads to naturally delegating the
responsibilities for building highly
scaled applications, allowing work to be done
independently on individual services without
impacting the work of other developers in other
groups working on the same overall application.
However, trying to get visibility into
this system can be very difficult.
When you have hundreds of services and
applications your request traveled through
debugging and troubleshooting can be a nightmare.
This is where open telemetry comes in.
As we already touched on telemetry is defined as
the science or process of collecting information
about objects that are far away and sending
the information somewhere electronically.
Now.
observability
means how well you can understand what is going
on internally in a system based on its outputs.
Especially as systems become
more distributed and complex.
It's hard to see what's going on inside your
application and why things may be going wrong.
When talking about observability, we need to
define the data types necessary to understand
the performance and health of our application
broadly, metrics, events, logs and traces.
Met, metrics are measurements collected at
regular intervals must have a timestamp and name,
one or more numeric values and a count
of how many events are represented.
These include error rate, response time or output.
An event is a discrete action happening
at any moment in time.
Take a vending machine.
For instance, an event could be the moment
when a user makes a purchase from the machine.
Adding metadata to events
makes them much more powerful.
With the vending machine example we
could add additional attributes such as
item category, and payment type.
This allows questions to be asked
such as how much money was
made from each item category,
or what is the most common payment type use.
logs come directly from your app,
exporting detailed data and
detailed context around an event.
So engineers can recreate what
happened millisecond by millisecond.
You have probably logged something when you use
things like system out print, or console log
traces follow a request from the
initial request to the returned output.
It requires the casual chain of
events to determine relationships
between different entities.
traces are very valuable for
highlighting inefficiencies, bottlenecks
and roadblocks in the user experience as
they can be used to show the end to end latency of
individual cores and a distributed architecture.
However, getting that data is very difficult.
You would have to manually instrument every
single service one by one layer by layer.
This will take as much time as writing the
code itself, which is annoying.
Luckily there are some awesome
open source projects as well as
companies that make this a lot easier
in today's 16 open tracing was released as a cn CF
project focused only around distributed tracing.
Because the libraries were lightweight and
simple, it could be used to fit any use case.
While it made it easy to instrument data, it made
it hard to instrument software that was shipped as
binaries without a lot of manual engineering work.
In 2018, a similar project called Open census was
open source out of Google, which supported both
the capturing retracing permission and metrics.
While it made it easier to get telemetry data
from software that was shipped as binaries
like Kubernetes, and databases, it made it hard to
use the API to instrument custom implementations,
not part of the default use case.
Both projects were able to make observability easy
for modern applications and expedite wide adoption
of distributed tracing by the software industry.
However, developers had to choose
between two options with pros and cons.
It turns out that the approaches of
the two projects were complimentary
rather than contradictory.
There was a no reason why we
couldn't have both the abstract vendor neutral
API and a well supported default implementation.
In late 2019, the two projects
merged to form opentelemetry.
This brought forward the idea
of having a single standard for
observability instead of two competing standards.
Okay, so first things first, let's go a bit meta
and understand exactly what is going to happen.
In order for us to view what
is happening in our app.
Here we have our project.
Think about project as a project we
have made with our code editors of choice.
For example, if we run it,
it runs locally on our machines.
Let's also say this project is
built to listen out for requests.
So like listening out for a get request,
for example, we have decided that we want
to measure our app's performance based on
the requests that it makes.
To do this, the first step
as we mentioned at the start, would be to
implement open telemetry into the project.
We are doing this to help us standardize the data.
Once we have implemented open telemetry
and standardize the data, we need to think
about what we are going to do with the data,
how we're going to view it, and so on.
For this, we can use an analysis tool.
By analysis tool, I mean, any type
of tool that gives you observability,
we are going to look at a few of these tools,
one that focuses specifically on tracing,
one that focuses specifically on metrics, and
one that looks at everything in one platform.
We are then going to send our data
to our analysis tool of choice.
Here we have an example of what our data can
look like in a tracing app such as zipkin,
a metrics app such as permittees, and an
observability tool such as New Relic that
will give us an overview of everything as well
as other more bespoke insights in one platform.
We will go into each of these
in their dedicated sections.
Let's start with implementing
open telemetry first.
Okay, so before we start, the only prerequisite
I am going to ask of you is that you
have Docker downloaded onto your machine.
Docker is a container platform for rapid
up microservices development, and delivery.
And if you don't know much about containers
and micro services, just stick with me for now.
I have a section dedicated to both of
these topics coming up after this section.
For those of you that don't have it,
please navigate to the Docker website
and follow the instructions.
In order to get set up.
I personally would choose to
download the Docker desktop.
As I am working on a Mac, I choose the Mac option.
Once you are done, make sure your Docker
desktop is running on a Mac, I would
simply hover over the icon like so.
You will see if you open up the platform
I currently have no containers running.
Having a container is going to be important
for when we get to using the analysis tools,
such as a tracing back end like zipkin.
Once we have all got Docker up and
running, let's get going.
Let's get our terminal up.
Now I'm going to navigate to a folder
where I like to store all my projects.
It's called development.
Please go ahead and choose
any directory that you would like to work in.
Now once here using the Mk dir command,
I'm going to make a folder for the
new project that I'm about to start.
I'm going to call it open telemetry starting out.
Please be aware that if you are using Different
terminal, other commands may need to be used.
Now, let's go into the project using
the command cd.
The first thing I'm
going to do is start our container.
So it's ready for the next section.
So, as mentioned, the first thing that you
need before you can start collecting traces
is a tracing back end like zipkin, that
you can export traces to, to set up zipkin
as quickly as possible, run the latest
Docker zipkin container, exposing Port 9411.
If you can't, or don't want
to run a Docker container,
you could also choose to download zipkin directly.
So just so you know, that is an option too.
If you want to explore that option more, I
would suggest visiting the zipkin website.
So this is the command to run our container.
And there we go, we now have this container ID,
it has worked.
Next up, we need to get a package JSON
file in our project, we can do so by typing NPM.
In it, having a package JSON file will make it
easier for others to manage and install
all the packages we need for the project.
If you are getting errors, it could be because
you don't have no js and NPM installed.
If that is the case, please visit node j s.org.
In order to get set up with that by
following the download instructions.
Okay, so we have initialized the utility,
I am just going to press enter for all
these fields, it's prompting me to answer.
So enter and, and, and, and enter.
OK, we are done creating our
package JSON file for now.
If we list out all the files on our project, using
the ls command, you will see the file right there.
Now finally, I need to create an app js file.
So a JavaScript file and put that in the project
to some of you might have a different
approach to adding files to a project.
So that is totally up to you, however
you'd like to create that file.
But once we are done, we now
need to open up our project.
As I am using VS code, I'm going to use the
command code.in order to open up our project.
And there we go.
There is a folder with an app
js file and a package JSON file.
You will see the package JSON file
has all the prompts we were asked,
as I skipped all the prompts is just the
standard default entries are no entries at all.
If you go to the app js file, you will also see
that it's currently empty, it has nothing in it.
Okay, so the first thing I need to do is change
this to point to the app js file we created
not the index j s as there is no index js file.
And just for fun, this is not necessary, I'm going
to fill out the description on my project.
So open telemetry costs.
The next thing I want to do
is just add a start script.
So for this script, I'm going to run node app j s.
Okay, now for the fun part,
let's get to adding some packages.
To start using open telemetry, we are going
to need to install some of its packages.
Using NPM II or install for short.
I'm going to store the open telemetry core
package, the open telemetry node package
opentelemetry plugin http opentelemetry.
plugin HTTP s, open telemetry exporters
zipkin to get us ready for the next section on
open telemetry tracing for the next section to
an express the only non open telemetry one.
Okay, so we need all of those to install.
Okay, and great.
So these are looking good.
So if we look back here, here are
the packages that we just installed.
They have automatically
populated our package JSON file.
So this is looking good.
We just missed one.
So let's go back and use NPM II or install for
short and install Open telemetry plug in Express.
And we are done.
Okay, now let's move on to our app js file.
The first thing I'm going to
do is define a port for us.
So const port, process and V port or a string of
Port 8080 Next up, we are going to need Express.
So const Express.
And Express is one of the packages we installed.
So this one right here.
So we need to tell our file that
this const requires Express.
We are then going to call Express
and stored as the const app.
The first thing I want to do is just
get a message in our console log to
let us know all is good, and that we
are listening out and on which port.
So just as a recap, what I am doing here
is getting the app to start a server.
And then with this code, I'm getting it to
listen out to our defined port for any requests.
Okay, next up, I'm going to paste
this super basic piece of code.
This code is an example of a very basic route.
routing refers to how an applications
end points respond to client requests.
We have defined the route using methods
of the Express app object that
corresponds to http methods.
For example, app get handles GET requests.
These routing methods specify a callback function
called when the application receives a
request to the specified route an HTTP method.
In other words, it listens out for requests
that much specified routes and methods.
In this case, the root is our homepage, we
essentially want to trace every single time
a get request is made to the homepage.
We will do this in the next section.
Now that we have the basic installation done,
it is now time for us to talk about tracing.
So as you know, open telemetry allows
us to essentially standardize our data.
The next part is actually viewing the data in a
way that we can analyze what is happening behind
the scenes, we will do this with a tracing system.
in software engineering tracing involves
a specialized use of logging to record
information about a program's execution.
This information is typically used by programmers
to debug by using the information contained
in a trace log to diagnose any problems that
might arise with a particular software or app.
Distributed tracing, however, also called
a distributed request tracing is a method
used to debug and monitor applications
built using a micro service architecture.
Distributed tracing helps pinpoint where
failures occur, and what causes poor performance.
So as we can now see, being able to
get tracing data telemetry is pretty
important to the overall performance of an app.
However, as we discussed in the introduction, due
to systems using all types of different languages,
frameworks and infrastructures, it's a hard thing
to do without some sort of common approach.
That's why Evans limitary can help
so much with distributed tracing.
By providing a common set of API's,
SDKs, and wire protocols.
It gives organizations a single,
well supported integration service for
end to end distributed tracing telemetry.
For this course, the tracer we're
going to be using is called zipkin.
zipkin is a distributed tracing system that helps
them gather timing data needed to troubleshoot
latency problems and service architectures.
Circuit was originally created by Twitter.
And it's currently run by the open
zipkin volunteer organization.
I am using zipkin for no other
reason than I had to pick one.
But please do feel free to choose any
back end tracing system that you wish,
the choice is completely up to you.
In general, once the traces are implemented
into applications, they essentially record timing
and metadata about operations that take place.
An example of this is when a web server
records exactly when it receives a request.
And when it sends a response.
This data is usually represented by a bar, just
like this, and goes by the official name of spam.
So in this example, we have two services
and a bunch of spans.
To explain this, imagine this
represents your favorite food delivery app.
So imagine you make an order right.
Now a few things will happen,
each represented by a span.
You send information back and forth from
services in order to make the payment,
find a delivery driver closest to you,
and notify that driver with your order.
Each of these operations generates a spam showing
you the work being done to make this happen.
In this case, the spans have implicit
relationships, so parent and child but
also from individual services and the trace.
As you can see, each of the spans starts at
a different point and takes
a different amount of time.
We call this latency and network latency.
In a nutshell, latency is delay between
an action and a response to that action.
network latency refers to specific delays
that take place within a network.
latency is generally measured in
milliseconds and is unavoidable due to the
way networks communicate with each other.
It depends on several aspects of a network
and can vary if any of them are changed.
errors on most systems are
usually quite easy to spot.
If your bar ends in red or similar, for
example, you know that an error has occurred.
Now it's time for us to look
at context and propagation.
These two concepts will allow us to
understand the topic of tracing a lot better.
So as we know distributed tracing allows us
to correlate events across service boundaries.
But how do we find these correlations for
this components in our distributed system
need to be able to collect, store and transfer
metadata? We refer to this metadata as context.
Context is divided into two types,
span context and correlation context.
span context represents the data required for
moving trace information across boundaries.
It contains the following metadata.
We have a trace ID, a span ID, the trace
flags and the trace state of this bond context.
And then we have the correlation context.
A correlation contacts carries
user defined properties.
This is usually things such as a
customer ID, providers, hearse name,
data region and other telemetry that gives
you application specific performance insights.
Correlation context is not required and components
may choose to not carry or store this information.
A context will usually have information so
we can identify the current span and trace
and propagation is the mechanism we use to bundle
up our context and transfer across services
so that we have it context and propagation.
Together.
These two concepts represent the
engine behind distributed tracing.
If you would like to learn more about these
two topics and do a deep dive at please
visit the urban telemetry website.
For the purpose of this tutorial,
however, a basic knowledge above will suffice.
So just as a bit of a heads up in this next
section, we will go through how to first
initialize a global tracer and after that
initialize and register a trace exporter.
Okay, so here we are where we left off.
Now in the last section, we ran the latest
Docker zipkin container exposing Port 9411.
If we actually visit localhost 9411, we will see
the zipkin UI that comes as part of doing that.
So here we are, this is what we are
going to use to view our traces.
Okay, let's carry on.
Next, let's create a file named tracing
and j s and add the following code.
This is just the sample code provided
to us by opentelemetry.
If you visit their website,
you can see I am just copying this code
right here and pasting it into my project.
You will also see that this file uses two of
the packages we installed in the initial setup.
Once we have pasted that we need to
initialize and register a trace exporter.
We have already done part of this as
we install two packages necessary for
this part and the initial setup section.
And that is the open telemetry tracing
and open telemetry export to zipkin packages.
So first off, let's make a new zipkin exporter.
So provide add span processor,
new simple span processor.
This is from the open telemetry tracing package,
as you can see that has shown up at the top
news of can export out.
And that also comes from another package.
So the open telemetry exporters, it can
package as you can see appearing at the top,
this might not automatically show up for you.
It's just the code editor I'm using.
So you might have to type those two out, and then
the right service name and choose a service now.
I'm going to put Getting Started but you
can replace it with your own service name.
Okay, that is looking good.
And so is the app js file.
Okay, great.
All tracing in a civilization
should happen before your application code runs.
The easiest way to do this is to initialize
tracing and a separate file that required using
the node r option before your application code
runs, I will show you what I mean by this.
So, now, if you run your application with node,
our tracing j s and app j s, your application
will create and propagate traces over HTTP.
So let's run that.
And now let's send
requests to application over HTTP.
We can do so simply by refreshing the
localhost 8080 page, you'll see traces exported
to our tracing back end, they look like this.
So he will see we are making a get request to the
homepage, which is responding with hello world.
And here we have getting started.
As that is what we called our service name.
We also get a start time and a duration as a span.
Now, as you use this more and more often,
some spans might appear to be
duplicated, but they are not.
This is because some applications can be both
the client and the server for these requests.
If this is the case, you will see one span
which is the client side request timing, and
one span which is the server side request timing,
anywhere that they don't overlap is network time.
Okay, now I'm going to show you one more example.
So just to differentiate, I'm going
to change my service name to get date.
Now I am going to go into my app js file.
I'm just going to copy this
piece of code right here.
And paste.
Now I want to essentially listen out to any
time a get request is made to the park date.
So in other words, if someone right now
went to localhost 8080 forward slash date,
that is us making a get request, we will also
be able to see respond with the actual date.
So let's go ahead, let's go back to our
localhost 8080 and type forward slash date.
Oops, I stopped my app running,
let's make sure it's running.
So I'm just going to start this up again.
Okay, and refresh our page.
And great, there is our object with today's date.
Amazing.
So now if we visit localhost 9411,
so the port we exposed, and click run a query,
we will see all the requests that have been made.
So there we go, we can now
see our get date service.
And at the moment, the only request we have
that it's listening out for is the get request.
Now, I have actually renamed the service,
remember so if I visit the homepage,
you will see that request is also being stored
under the get date service name, you can tell
which one it is by the timestamp.
Okay, let's move on.
Okay, we are now done with a
basic implementation of tracing.
However, we are literally
just touching the surface.
In the project portion of our course I
will show you how to use open telemetry
to instrument a distributed system.
By this I mean I will show you how
to trace multiple services and their
interactions with each other if those exist.
In this next section, we're going to learn
how to collect metrics with open telemetry and
remediate Prometheus as a monitoring platform
that collects metrics from monitor targets by
scraping metrics HTTP endpoints on these targets.
In this section, I will show you how to install,
configure and monitor our fast app
with Prometheus and open telemetry.
We will download, install and run Prometheus to
expose time series data on hosts and services.
Unlike tracing which works in spans metrics
are a numeric representation of data
measured over intervals of time.
metrics can harness the power of
mathematical modeling and prediction to derive
knowledge of the behavior of a system over
intervals of time in the present and future.
Since numbers are optimized for storage,
processing, compression and
retrieval, metrics enable longer
retention of data as well as easier querying.
This makes metrics perfectly suited to building
dashboards that reflect historical trends.
metrics also allow for gradual
reduction of data resolution.
After a certain period of time, data can
be aggregated into daily or weekly frequency.
Let's have a look at this in action.
In this section, I'm going to be using
promethium as my metrics backend.
Now that we have set up end to end traces,
we can collect and export some basic metrics.
First, I'm going to stop this from running.
Let's go to the Prometheus download page
and download the latest release.
permittees for your operating system.
As I'm using a Mac, I'm going
to click on this one right here.
Once that has downloaded open a command line and
use CD or the command cd to go into the directory,
where you downloaded the promethease tarball.
In my case, it will be the Downloads directory.
Now I need to unretire it into the newly created
directory, make sure that you replace the file
name with your downloaded harbor.
So don't necessarily use this one.
And now let's go into the directory.
If I list out all the files and folders,
you will see a file named permit this yamo this
is the file used to configure permit Yes, for now,
just make sure permit is start by running the dot
four slash promethease binary and the folder and
browse to localhost 9090.
Okay, great.
And that is our promethease user interface.
So you will see this as server is ready
to receive web requests.
So that should be all good.
I am just going to go ahead and open up a new
tab right here so I can keep that running.
And I'm going to open up our
directory using the VS code shortcut.
Once we have confirmed that
permit the US has started,
we need to replace the contents of the
primitives yamo file with the following.
So literally just delete everything and
put in this much shorter piece of code.
This will set the scrape
interval to every 15 seconds.
We are now ready to monitor
our Node JS application.
In this next section, we need to initialize
the required open telemetry metrics library,
initialize a meter and collect metrics and
initialize and register a metrics exporter.
To do this, we are going to
have to install some libraries,
we are going to need the open
telemetry metrics package.
So let's go ahead and install that.
Let's navigate back to our project first.
So don't do this in the
directory we just downloaded.
And in here, type NPM II or
install Open telemetry metrics.
Great, we are now ready to initialize
a meter and collect metrics.
We first need a meter to create and monitor
metrics a meter and open telemetry is the
mechanism used to create and manage
metrics, labels, unmetric exporters,
create a file named monitoring j s.
So a JavaScript file and the root of your folder
and add the following code.
So we're going to need the
open telemetry metrics package for this Kant's.
And we're gonna get the meter provider from it
and buy it I mean, the open telemetry metrics
package, we are then going to make a new
console constant meter.
And we're going to use the
meter provider we're gonna make a
new meter provider and use get meter,
as well as I'm just gonna put your meter name
for now, we can change this whenever we want.
Now we can require this file from your
application code and use the meter
to create and manage metrics.
The simplest of these metrics is a counter.
In this next part, we're going to create
an export from our monitoring js file,
a middleware function that express can
use to count all requests made by route.
So first off, we need to
modify IO monitoring j s file.
So once again, I'm just going to copy this
sample code from open telemetry open source
projects in order to help us count the requests
and paste that into my monitoring j s file.
Next, we need to import and use this
middleware in our application code.
So our app js file.
So we need to get count
all requests from our monitoring js file.
So the module export, we do so by typing
const count all requests require monitoring j s.
So literally, we are using this right here.
Now let's get to using it.
Type app use count all requests and call it now
when you make requests your service you
will meter will count all the requests.
Perfect.
Next up, let's
look at initializing and registering a metrics
exporter counter metrics are only useful if you
can export them somewhere where you can see that.
For this we're going to use Prometheus is creating
and registering a metrics exporter is
much like the tracing exporter above fast,
you need to install the Prometheus
exporter by running the following command.
So I'm just going to use npm install
and open telemetry exporter permit this
next step, we need to add some more
code to our monitoring js file.
So once again, I'm going to copy the code
given to us by opentelemetry To get started,
and paste it into my monitoring js file.
Don't worry, I will share this repo with
all of you so that if you do get stuck,
you can refer to my finished project.
Now in a separate tab, so just leave
this running and show Prometheus is
running by running the Prometheus binary
from earlier and start your application.
We do so by using the script we wrote.
So NPM start, you should see promethease
scrape endpoint and the HTTP localhost
94644 slash metrics, as well as
listening for requests on localhost 8080.
Now, each time you browse to localhost 8080,
you should see Hello, in your browser and
your metrics, and Prometheus should update,
you can verify the current metrics
by browsing to localhost 9464,
forward slash metrics, which should look
like this, you should also be able to see
the gathered metrics in your Prometheus web UI,
we can also add more routes in our app js file.
Let's go ahead and do that to
see what that would look like.
So I'm just going to add
some pre written code here.
And that is a middle tier route, and
another route that has the pot back end.
So now we have our date, homepage from the
previous section, our back end route now,
and a middle tier route, as
well as a new homepage route.
I'm also going to need axios for this.
So another package that will
help me in making these requests.
So let's go ahead and import that into my project.
And nice that is done.
Let's run NPM start.
Okay, now let's check everything
is working as expected.
The home page now responds with Hello backend.
This is actually because we
have two homepage routes.
So I'm just going to get rid
of the other one in a bit.
The backend route responds with Hello back
end, the date route responds with today's date.
So that looks good.
So I'm just going to
delete the initial homepage route that we had that
responds with hello world and keep the new one.
Okay, and now let's visit middle tier.
And we get response of Hello backend.
And finally, let's visit matrix where we get a
request counter of all the routes we have visited.
Okay.
So this
looks like it's all working, we visited all the
routes, and I counter seems to be working fine.
Now let's go ahead and see
that in the permittees UI.
So we're going to have to
pick something to execute.
And there we go.
Now, before we move on to our project,
I thought let's take a little bit of time to
understand exactly what issues can be detected.
With open telemetry.
Here's just a list
that I'm going to go through with you.
Starting with the backend.
In the backend with open telemetry you can pick
up bad logic or user input, leading to exceptions
being thrown, poorly implemented downstream calls.
So for example to infrastructures like databases
or downstream API's, leading to
exceptionally long response times.
Or you can pick up poorly performant code on a
single API, leading to exceptional response times.
On the front end, with open telemetry,
you can detect bad logic or user input
leading to JavaScript errors.
You can also use it to find
poorly implemented JavaScript, making your UI
prohibitively slow, despite performant API's.
And you can even use it to locate geo
specific slowness requiring geo distribution.
And finally, for infrastructure, you can use it to
identify noisy neighbors running on a host sapping
resource from other apps, configuration changes,
leading to performance degeneration version audit.
So zero day vulnerability checks,
ensuring convict changes went through,
or just miss figuration with your
DNS making your apps inaccessible.
So that is a list of you thinking of issues
that you can detect with open telemetry.
Now that we have that covered,
let's move on to our project.
And this part of the course, I want to show
you what happens when you are building out
an app with a more complicated back
end that deals with two services.
It is a hypothetical project that you can adapt
to anything that you wish, it is an app that gets
movies for your database.
By the end of the project,
you will be able to trace exactly how we
got the movies, and how long each step took.
Okay, so here is a project I have pre made,
thanks to the open source community and inspired
by an open telemetry contributor, Alan storm.
It is a project that has two services with one
service relying on the other,
but not the other way around.
In this project, I have a main dashboard
service, as well as the movies service,
which will return all the movies for our app.
The layout of this project is similar to what
we did in the tracing setup.
However, instead of having a
separate tracing js file to trace each
service, the code is directly in each file.
So as you can see, each service
is in the root of our project.
And just going to minimize this so we
can see the code a little better now.
So from the beginning of our
course, this should look familiar.
So as a reminder, open telemetry requires that
we instantiate a trace provider, configure
that trace provider with an exporter
and install Open telemetry plugins to
instrument specific node modules.
Let's talk through the code.
So we can see here as a refresher, especially
as it's organized in a different way than
what we saw in the basic implementation.
So first, we are going to get the node trace
provider from the open telemetry node package.
A trace provider is what will help us
create traces on no Jess.
Next, we will get the console
span exporter and the simple span processor
from the open telemetry tracing package.
And then we need to get the zipkin exporter
from the open telemetry exporter zipkin package.
Now that we have what is necessary, let's move on.
So at the moment, we have made a tracing program.
And to actually generate the spans if you
remember, we installed a plugin called
Open telemetry plugin dash HTTP,
the node a trace provider object is smart enough
to notice the presence of a plugin and load it.
This code creates a trace provider
and adds a span of processor to it.
The trace processor requires an exporter.
So we instantiate that as well.
Both are responsible for getting the telemetry
data out of your service and into another system.
With this code, we create an exporter then
use that exporter when creating a span
processor, and then added that spam
processor to our trace provider.
Okay, so that is what that code does.
Let's actually name our service.
Now, I have left this blank.
So let's go ahead and fill that in.
As this service is going to
deal with the main service,
I'm just going to call it dashboard service.
Here we're instantiating, a zipkin.
exporter, and then adding
it to the trace provider.
We of course need to get Express
from the package Express.
And so a server and listen out on
port 3000 on one four connections.
The app is currently not going to respond with
anything for requests any part as
we haven't written anything yet.
I wanted to respond with the dashboard
itself and the movies from the movie service.
But before we do that, we need
to build out our movies js file.
So this file is exactly the same as the other file
just perhaps with some code in different places.
uses a different port.
In this file, I want to deal with the movies.
So I'm just going to rename this
service name to movies service.
If I ran this service, we would
be listening out to Port 3000.
Now, I'm going to determine how our app responds
to a get request to the movies endpoint.
So I am just going to write up, get, and
then I'm simply going to put the movies path.
So I'm making this up.
This is an async function, and I'm going
to pass through a request and response.
Okay, so there we go.
And then I'm simply going to
type rest type Jason as a string.
And response, send Jason stringify.
And I'm just going to send a movie object
with, let's say, an array of movies.
So let's put some objects in our array, I'm
going to make the array have movie objects.
And each movie object is going to have a name.
So a name like Jaws, a genre.
So for example, jaws is a thriller as
a string, and that is my first object.
And then I'm just going to
make a quick other object.
This time, let's put a different type of film.
So I'm just going to put the string of Ani,
and once again, let's put a genre.
So I'm just making the same movie
object just with a different name and genre.
I'm going to put family and make another object.
I'm going to stop after this one, because
this is just for illustration purposes.
And let's put Jurassic Park as the
name and let's put action as the genre.
Okay, that is it.
That's our array of three movie objects.
Okay, now let's run our app.
So let's actually go to
localhost 3000, and put the movies path.
So what I'm doing is I am requesting the URL.
And of course, our app is going to
listen out for it and make a trace.
So now let's go over to the zipkin
UI and search for recent traces,
we will see we recorded a single service trace.
However, if we look through into the trace
details, we'll see these traces do not
look like the traces we've previously seen.
In our previous examples,
one span equaled one service.
However, a span is just a span of time
that's related to other spans of time,
we can use a span to measure any
individual part of our service as well.
The Express auto instrumentation plugin creates
spans that measure actions within the Express
framework, we can use it to find out how long
each middleware took to execute, how long your
Express handler took to execute, and so on.
It gives you insights not just into what's
going on with the service as a whole, but
also individual parts of your Express system.
This is the role most of the contract
plugins play in the open telemetry project.
The core plugins are concerned with ensuring
each request is bound to a single trace.
But the contract plugins will create spans
specific to the behavior
of a particular framework.
Okay, great.
Let's carry on.
So now that we've done that, I want
to show you how to use open telemetry
to instrument a distributed system.
This is what our dashboard js file
is for is essentially want my dashboard js
file to call the movies service as well.
So let's get to writing that code.
The first thing I am going to do is
actually use the node fetch library
which we haven't installed yet.
So this service, use the node fetch
library to call our movies service.
Let's go ahead and install that.
So I'm just going to get my terminal
and type NPM I for install and node batch.
Okay, now, once again, I'm going to have to
type apt get, and then use the route of dashboard
and then write in async function, so a sick
function and pass through a request and response.
Now I am going to write here I need to fetch
data from a second service.
And that's the movie service.
I'm just gonna write some pseudocode to remind us
of that, fetch data running from second service
and My second service is the movies service.
Okay, now, I am going to write a function that
will essentially help us get all the
URL contact from the movies service.
So essentially our object with the three movies
in an array or movie objects in an array.
So let's get to writing this
function, I'm going to write this
function and pass through two parameters.
So whenever I pass through a URL into this
function and a fetch, so the fetch is
actually going to use our node fetch library,
then I'm going to use these two parameters
to essentially get the body of that URL.
So I'm going to use a promise
to do this new promise,
I'm going to pass through resolve and reject.
And then I'm going to use fetch to fetch the URL.
And then whatever is in the body, I'm going
to use so fetch URL, resolve reject, then
Russ, Russ text, then body.
So that is my function for
getting the URL content.
Let's get to using that.
Okay, I'm just going to actually change this.
I don't like the way this is written.
And I want to make it consistent with the bottom.
So I'm just going to change this up.
So it looks a bit neater is just a
different way of writing functions.
So just so it's consistent to that.
Okay.
So once again, let's go down
to the code I've pre written.
And in here, I'm going to fetch data
running from the second service.
So the movies service, I am going to actually
save the contents of the URL as movies.
So const movies, await and use the function
that we pre wrote to pass through the URL.
So the URL we want to get the content of is HTTP
localhost 3004 slash movies.
So there we go, that is ju L.
It is the same URL that I have written here.
So URL U, r, l, that's what we have done.
And then I'm going to need to require node fetch.
So I'm going to look through right require
and the package node fetch, I'm going to put
rest type Jason, and rez send Jason stringify.
And now I'm going to write the word dashboard.
Okay, so I'm making an object, and I'm gonna
write dashboard, and then whatever we've
saved as movies should show up here.
So essentially, the contents
of the URL will show up here.
Okay, so now I cannot run this file.
So I could run this file,
but we will see an error.
This is because our file relies
on the movies service being up and running.
So I'm just going to show you now I'm going
to type node dashboard, j.
s.
So it's listening at localhost 3001.
However, if I visit localhost 3001 for
slash dashboard, I get an error.
This is because we need our
movie service to be running.
So let's go ahead and make that true.
I'm just going to open up a new
tab and type node movies j s.
Okay, that is not running and
listening at Port localhost 3000.
So now, here's our movies.
And let's refresh
or let's rerun the dashboard.
So once again, node dashboard, j s.
And then refresh our page.
Amazing, we will see our
dashboard object with the contents of
the URL from the Ford slash movies path.
Amazing.
So this is working fine.
Our code is working as it should.
Now, let's see how this looks in our zipkin UI.
So I'm just going to rerun the
query and look at our latest.
And there we go.
So once again, to reiterate that,
in a nutshell, the dashboard service is
dependent on a movie service to populate it.
This is true for many apps
you interact with today,
and which is why this example is the one
I wanted to show you for our project.
Now, we can see here that each span
from the services are linked together.
The opentelemetry HTTP plugin took care of
this for us, the node fetch plugin use the
underlying functionality of node j,
s, HTTP and HTTPS to make requests.
So that's how to instrument an
application using open telemetry.
Like this is pretty cool, as obviously,
you can see our dashboard service,
and then you can see exactly what time it's going
to the get movies, service, and then coming back.
Okay, that brings us to the end of our project.
I hope you've enjoyed this section.
This is, of course, just the surface
of what you can do the opentelemetry.
There is a lot more to it.
But until you get the fundamentals,
I sincerely hope you can go through
this course again and again until you
feel more comfortable building your own projects.
So far, in this project, we have directly gotten
data from an app and send the data to zipkin.
But what happens if we want to try sending it to
another back end to process our telemetry data?
Does that mean we would have to
re instrument our whole app? Well,
the amazing contributors to open telemetry
have come up with a solution to fix this.
The open telemetry collector is
a way for developers to receive
process and export telemetry
data to multiple backends.
It supports open source observability data formats
like zipkin, Jaeger permittees, or flume bit,
sending it to one or more open
source or commercial backends.
In this next section, I'm going
to show you how to use it.
Okay, so for this section, and using the open
telemetry collector, we're going to be using New
Relic as our observability tool of choice.
All I'm going to do is head over
to New Relic and sign up.
Next, you'll see some questions,
please answer these to the best of your ability.
So for example, where you store your data, and
just click save, your account will then be set up.
Once you get to this page right here, I'm just
going to ask you to not interact with anything
for now, and head over to one dot new relic.com.
Once here, I'm going to ask you to go on the
drop down of your profile and click API keys.
Once here, I'm going to ask
you to gravitate to creating a
new queue and just select ingest license.
I'm going to name this otol example.
And I'm just gonna give it some notes
just so we can keep track of our API keys.
And great, our API key is now created.
Let's copy it and move on.
The next thing we're going to do is
actually get our open telemetry collector.
For this, I'm going to head
over to New Relic GitHub account
in which I can get the open telemetry examples.
So I'm just going to ask you to clone this repo
into your local machine.
I have already done this.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and head over to that repo now.
And here it is.
Once here, I'm going to ask
you to navigate to the collectors and our exporter
Docker otol config yamo file, because we're gonna
have to change this up a little bit.
So please do head over here now.
And I'm just going to ask you
to add a little line of code.
This line of code will add zipkin as
a receiver, a receiver is aware that
data gets into the open telemetry collector.
So because we already have our app configured
to use zipkin, we will be telling
the open telemetry collector Hey,
we will be sending you data in the form of zipkin.
So that is what is happening, we are adding
zipkin as a receiver and then giving it an
endpoint, which in this case is 0.0 dot 09411.
Now because zipkin report tracing data, we
are going to add zipkin as a tracing receiver
underneath service.
And that's it.
The next thing we need to do is go
over to the Docker compose yamo file,
and make sure that the Docker container
that runs this open telemetry collector
is actually able to receive the data through the
same port that it would have if it was zipkin.
So we're going to add the Port
9411, just like so and save it.
Now, according to the readme to run this,
we need to use the API key we just created.
So in my terminal, I'm just
going To export the New Relic
API key I just created with this command.
Next, we need to spin up the Docker container with
this command, making sure of course
that we are in the correct directory.
So that is my fault.
Let's go into that directory.
So the nr exporter Docker.
And once again, we run the Docker container.
and wonderful.
Now let's go back to our movies dashboard project
that we have been working for in this course.
So now I just need to modify our app ever
since Thirdly, to work with
the open telemetry collector.
For this to work, we need to change two things,
we need to change the URL that is reporting at.
So this one right here, I'm
simply going to use it like so.
So we need to do is for the dashboard
and also for the movies service.
And that's it.
Now, I'm just
going to reinstall all the dependencies for
those who are just joining us here and I've
taken this project from the description below.
And then let's run the two services, like we have
been doing previously in this tutorial.
Wonderful.
Okay, now I'm just going to call the
services by visiting the dashboard service.
As a reminder, the dashboard service
relies on the movies service,
I'm going to call it multiple times, so we
can get lots and lots of data to work with.
So maybe just a few more.
Okay, done.
Let's move on.
Now that we have our app and have successfully
instrumented the open telemetry collector
that is forwarding our data to New Relic,
we should now be able to visualize our data.
For this, we need to go to the
Explorer tab on New Relic.
And once here, we will see the two services,
the dashboard service and the movies service, just
like in the previous distributed tracing section.
Let's deep dive further.
As you can see in the
dashboard service, that was a spike.
Let's find out what was happening.
So it looks like there were 18 traces with nine
spans and two entities for the dashboard service.
That sounds right.
Great.
And if we dig deeper, you will see
the micro service that our dashboard
service was communicating with to
actually solve the final result.
Wonderful.
As you can see, we can get a lot of awesome
data to do things such as get to the root cause
analysis of what could be going wrong in your app,
check how your microservices are
performing, and so, so much more.
Okay, and there we have it.
That was our open telemetry course,
before we finish, I just want to take a moment
to recap what we have learned in this course.
So to recap, in this course, we learnt
how to set up the back end for a project.
Then we learnt how to implement tracing into
our project, as well as metrics if we need to.
And then we also looked at two
services and how they communicate.
Thanks to distributed tracing.
I hope you now feel comfortable knowing the
benefits of using open telemetry, as well as have
a good understanding of how you would go about
implementing it into your Node JS projects.
If you are wondering where to go next,
with your newfound knowledge, I would
suggest learning about infrastructure
monitoring and digital experience monitoring.
These are two other ways to visualize, analyze
and troubleshoot your entire software stack.
I will leave you with this and a link to
New Relic To find out more and get a
free account with no expiration date.
Thanks so much again for
watching and I'll see you soon